bronx zoo named two animals after you
guys animals not animals they're not two
hissing cockroaches is that true yes yes
that's true there are two hissing
cockroaches at the bronx zoo named nick
kroll and john mulaney yeah
we have not gone to see them because i
assume there's like a hundred
cockroaches and they're like ah that's
nick and john
did you just point to two cockroaches
yeah it feels slightly anti-semitic to
call a jew a cockroach
i'm fine with mine but his is a direct
insult yeah
the irish we don't give a [ __ ] no we
don't call it anything yeah
anything we love it yeah but we're happy
to be in zoos we love zoos i love going
to the zoo have you ever been to a zoo i
have been to have people been to the zoo
it's like a museum of living animals
it's wonderful
uh people been to zoos i like to talk to
the people okay
we actually have gone to a lot of that
is the one thing we will like like call
and try to use our tiny amount of fame
for is to go behind the scenes at zoos
and it's worked numerous times wait you
call up and say we want to go behind
yeah
we met the pandas at the smithsonian zoo
in washington dc we met tienten the
father
maejong the mother and babe
the baby which to me seems like a
short-sighted name yeah
you don't want to meet an old panda on
the streak what's your name i'm bae bae
yeah oh boy i think new kids on the
block yeah the 60s yeah for real yeah
and it was great we got to interact with
them they ate a lot of bamboo and
carrots yeah and they poop them out yeah
and you can turn uh their poop into
paper
what you can take panda poop if they've
been eating enough bamboo and you can
turn it into paper yeah this is the kind
of stuff you find out if you call the
zoo
you can also you can also though go to
staples yeah yeah and buy paper yeah but
yeah
i don't wait online yeah
have you guys you guys been to a zoo and
you know what staples is yeah
this is the state this is an office
supply store
and a zoo is like the movies but instead
of a screen it's bars and instead of
acting it's like a lemur
meerkat or a lazy lizard yeah but now
there's another panda at the smithsonian
zoo named baobao and baba is going to
china
we have an exchange program with china
at least we do now i don't know what the
white house is doing to sever that
was going back to china and i was like
what's it what's it gonna do there i
asked the zookeeper and they're like the
pandas are from china right like i was
picturing it living in an apartment or
something
yeah and like he doesn't know the bus
system yeah
like we're like working at an iphone
factory yeah
panda stuff
well you guys you get around you see
things and you do things that's the
important thing that's a compliment
[Applause]